in the previous video I showed my PDP
1173 that came quite late in the history
of PDP 11 whereas what we brought in
here is a replica a modern replica based
on a Raspberry Pi although much earlier
PDP 11 the pdp-11 70 and these were much
more visually interesting they had sort
of flashing lights on the front and
toggle switches that you can you know
pipe up and down in order to program the
machine so it comes as a kit we have
been setting this not an advert for them
but I do think is a pretty cool kit so
we have a bag full of switches we have
LEDs and a couple of chips and some
diodes and some resistors this is the
front panel let's see how quickly I can
peel off the yeah very brief overview
these are the LEDs showing the data in
the currently selected address the LEDs
showing the current address the few
status LEDs to show kind of what mode
the pdp-11 is in and then you can switch
these addresses and data to different
registers and things with the rotary
switches on the right and then we have
this board so we're going to solder up
some of this today maybe not all of it
and on the back here we put a Raspberry
Pi so may not have been very sensible it
is to Hilo so I think I might trap these
bits in the case alright so let's start
with the smallest components that's
going to be sort of this row of diodes
across here these diets do have to go in
the right way I think I'm only gonna do
two or something is the wrong way around
try not to fix hold on your lens as well
see how they've done that quite nice
actually only three diodes but yeah
we're not actually gonna build this
entire thing right now it took me about
three hours and I had a sandwich in the
middle so quite a bit smaller than a
actual pdp-11 70 so pdp-11 70 would meet
some 19 inches I'm using Imperial
because that's how they measure the
racks and it would be I don't know how
so you have sort of the control panel
which is of this big and then under that
you have the card cage so quite a lot
larger than this thing but most people
don't want a full pdp-11 70 in the house
although if you want to send me one
that's fine so let's talk a little bit
about pdp-11 in general and then we can
kind of explain the console a little bit
more the PDP series of computers was
basically all based around octal so all
of the word sizes of these PDP's was in
multiples of six pre ASCII and in order
to represent kind of the full character
set you it needs six bits so your word
length of the machine would be sort of
12 or 36 or you know 18 so that was
convenient as well because we could
think about instructions or code
listings in octal so each digit would be
three switches on the front of here the
pdp-11 though was late 60s early 70s
when ascii was really sort of taking off
and you know all computers were going to
be using ASCII so the side effect of
that is that we wanted 8-bit word length
machines or 16 you know multiples of 8
so an interesting side effect of dec
wanting to stick with this optimal
notation while also switching to ASCII
and 8-bit based word lengths is that we
have sort of three switches and three
switches and three switches
so you know zero through two seven on
each of these with in at the very end
this 21 bits the most significant bit on
the machine is just on its own it's all
alone so you can see they were clinging
on to octal and they didn't want to give
it up I think we should probably enter a
small program you're using the switches
will chase a light across the screen
that's generally like sort of the hello
world when you don't have a terminal
with you when you first set up the PI DP
11 and first boot up it will kind of do
this idle LED pass on a actual PDP 1170
would knit on this we would just wait
and do nothing
so I have on my phone here a short
program which is I think commonly called
chasing light so what we're gonna do is
we're going to halt and reset the
machine well we're going to make sure we
put the right address in so we're
starting at 1,000 load address and we're
going to say so 5,000 deposit 5 2 0 0 so
each time you do this you're selecting
with something that's like writing a
number and then you're saying write put
this in a register yeah you're actually
putting it straight into that's yeah
that's just the default so once you
deposit it increments the address
register so you don't have to you know
manually insert the address first and
load it and then you I mean this is a
lot of work so you wouldn't want to do
this for you wouldn't want to sort of
yeah type in the address and then also
toggle in the data that you want in
there so I'm gonna put this back to 0
and then 1000 which is our starting
address load that and unhold and then
continue what they done wrong if not
that see the thing is I grew up in an
age where we had to type in in basic new
program listings and that felt like it
was really hard work
and now I'm seeing the well yeah so this
was 20 years before yeah yeah so the
Busey was 82 and this was sort of late
60s yeah yeah probably we're gonna I'm
gonna reset a whole machine which is
there's a secret kind of reset button on
here on the PI DP 11 so let's see
it's finally running we tried it a
couple of times to enter it I think
sometimes because there's a simulator
running in the background interrupting
it from what it's currently doing and
trying I think it introduces an extra
layer of sort of problems whereas a
actual pdp-11
you would enter the program and
hopefully overdrawn probably the first
time but we got it running so you can
see there is an LED chasing directly
across the screen at the moment we can
actually hold this machine and then we
can run it one instruction at a time so
you see the address register
incrementing by one each time and every
few instructions this will jump across
to the left until it wraps back around
yeah overflows and comes back to its
zero this machine is so much faster than
an actual pdp-11
the speed at which it's chasing across
the screen is one not screen but you
know the console is office and it would
be on on a an actual pdp-11
essentially what this program is doing
is we clear the register zero we
increment it by one so that it has you
know a bit in it and then we rotate that
register to the left once we reset the
bus which just adds a little bit of a
delay so that we can actually see the
LEDs changing and then finally we jump
back to instructions so they rotate so
when this bit gets to the end of the
sixteen bits it wraps around back two
bit zero so we we see this bit moving
very quickly from address zero to
sixteen I would ideally like my pdp-11
to be on 24/7 at home but that would
cost me about three hundred pounds a
year whereas this is five watts and
that's about five pounds a year when
this is a home I have it now running a
web server maybe I can give Shawn a link
and we can see if we can crash it with
some swarms of people that'll be fun I
mean that's that's the other thing
because it simulated you you can just
take it back up of your SD card and if
something goes wrong you can go straight
back to it so when you're actually
playing with hardware there's so many
things that can go wrong from like
you know disks crashing on our lo2
drives power supplies failing it's
always a fun repair but in this I mean
it depends if you're more interested in
the software or the hardware I think I'm
more interested and I like them both
send me a few fuel Evan I'm gonna
disconnect it from from the mains I
think it should be fine anyway but I
will spin it around I'll just remove
these ribbon k
we probably wouldn't get one when the
mouse is moved if you think about as the
mouse is being moved you've got lots and
lots of events most of